There are four fundamental forces of
nature as we now understand it,
there's gravity and electromagnetism,
which are the classic forces which were
known already in prehistory and uh,
and known in some form to the ancient
Greeks,
but which had mature theories in the
case of gravity already in the 17th
century with Newton,
end of the 19th century with Maxwell and
very beautiful descriptions in and in
case of gravity made even more beautiful
with Einstein's general theory of
relativity in the early 20th century,
but in the course of studying a
subatomic physics and in what goes on at
a very,
very short distances,
people found they needed to additional
forces like gravity and electromagnetism
aren't enough,
and the two additional forces are called
the strong and weak forces.
What I got the Nobel prize for was
figuring out the equations of the strong
force and equally important,
not just guessing the equations,
but showing how you could test them and
see that they were right.
This was something I did as a graduate
student.
I was of course working very closely
with my thesis advisor at very,
very gifted and a powerful physicist
named David.
Gross,
uh,
what,
so how did we go about doing it?
Well,
uh,
there were some,
there were the experimental situation
regarding the strong interaction was
very confused,
desperately confused.
There was no theory even remotely worthy
of standing behind beside Newton's
theory of gravity or Einstein's or
maxwell's theory of electromagnetism.
They were just a lot of rules of thumb
and a lot of confusing data.
What we did was focus on one particular
phenomena and try to understand just
that
putting off all other aspects of this
confusing a situation.
The phenomena we tried to understand
seems so paradoxical,
so crazy that we thought if we could
understand that we could understand
anything,
uh,
basically,
and uh,
and also seen because it seems so
profound and fundamental.
Uh,
actually David thought that we could
prove that it couldn't,
that you couldn't just couldn't
understand that within the standard
framework of quantum mechanics and
relativity.
And that would be a very important
result too because we'd tell a physicist
they had to go back to the drawing
board.
This aspect that we were trying to
explain was the fact that
corks,
which were somewhat speculative,
but a pretty clear indication of reality
at that time when they get close
together,
hardly interact at all or when they're
moving at very high velocity relative to
one of them there at high energy.
Again,
they don't interact very much at all,
but if you try to pull them apart,
a significant distance,
which means in this case,
10 to the minus 13 centimeters or more,
uh,
or if they're moving slowly,
then they,
uh,
have very,
very powerful forces.
In fact,
you can't extract single corks from
matter.
They always exist bound to one another
inside protons and neutrons.
So we needed a force which gets weaker
at short distances and grows as the
distance growth.
That's a very paradoxical and difficult
thing to imagine and make consistent
with the other laws of physics that we
know,
uh,
now there were powerful mathematical
techniques.
We're investigating that kind of
question that had been developed in
other for other purposes called
renormalization group.
So we were able to bring those
techniques to bear and address this
question.
And they were very difficult
calculations,
uh,
it wasn't entirely clear that they were
concise,
consistent that you could actually do
this kind of calculation in the kind of
theory that there was most beautiful
that we wanted to investigate.
Uh,
but we insisted on hoping that the most
beautiful equations would be the right
equations.
And we found out that a very,
very special class of theoretical,
uh,
constructions with tremendous amounts of
symmetry a could give you this behavior.
So that was,
that was,
I like to say that I compare that to a
archimedes saying that if you give me a
lever and a place to stand,
I can lift the world based on that kind
of a
leverage given by the sort of basic
principles and faith in symmetry and
beauty.
Plus this one fact about the force is
getting weaker.
We will lead to quite a unique proposal
for what the equations of the strong
interaction should be.
And we could develop some consequences
of those equations and then propose to
experimenters that they go out and check
whether these consequences are correct.
Now it took several years afterwards
before it became clear that those
consequences we predicted were correct,
but they are,
and in subsequent years that's become
more and more clear.
The theory has been used for a wide
variety of applications now with great
success and the kind of thing that in
the early days was called testing
quantum chromo dynamics or testing
asymptotic freedom is now cold
calculating backgrounds.
So it's gone from being a glamorous
exploration of new worlds to kind of
taking care of the garbage so that you
could,
uh,
you can look for more interesting
things.
But,
uh,
it's,
well,
although it sounds in a way,
it's kind of a,
a step down in a few if I,
you know,
look at it in the big picture.
It's glorious that you have a theory
that was originally very speculative and
just something that existed in our
minds,
you know,
and we had.
And it's gone now too.
Being an absolutely accepted and basic
part of our understanding of nature and
a very beautiful.